what are the average ages of your
students you're a professor yes i'm a
professor and my students are from what
18 to 22 mainly okay and they've grown
up in this contemporary world and often
i'm just astounded i'm just astounded at
what they're unfamiliar with
uh you know
i had one wonderful student the other
day we were talking about
great films and great performances and
so on and
i said something about marlon brando and
uh
made
some comment about his uh performance
and he said yeah i'd like to talk a bit
but who's marlon brando
and you know uh you say to yourself oh
my goodness
we really have lost some connection with
our own heritage and
that's one of the wonderful things you
can do while studying film history too
you can bring that a little bit back so
they're 18 to 22 and they're living in a
world which is entirely
post-9 11
and
i think they're
more
fretful and anxious
than students here for because these
people are more frightful unanxious
than we were and i guess movies are
reflecting that